Hey, welcome to the Tap Read Therapy Collective podcast. We're talking about LI today and I'm not trained in lifespan integration therapy, but it's another brain-based medicine that's emerging that I'm interested in. I've seen a lot of patients that have had it. I've talked to a lot of providers that really like it a lot that do similar things to it that I do like brain spotting. And I'm here with three therapists at Taproot that are trained in LI and can talk about it with a lot more surety than me. Marie Danner, Pamela Hayes, and Kristen Baer. So thank you guys for being here today. And let's talk about lifespan integration. How do you use lifespan integration? Like kind of like, what brought you to it? And then maybe we can go over kind of a brief history of it, not too academic.
嘿，欢迎收听 Taproot Therapy Collective 播客。我们今天讨论的是 LI（生命周期整合疗法），虽然我没有接受过生命周期整合疗法的专业培训，但它是目前新兴的另一种基于大脑的疗法，我对此很感兴趣。我见过很多接受过这种疗法的患者，也和很多非常喜欢它的治疗师交流过，他们所做的和我所做的（比如脑点疗法）有很多相似之处。今天和我在一起的三位治疗师都来自 Taproot，她们受过 LI 培训，能比我更确切地谈论它。她们是 Marie Danner、Pamela Hayes 和 Kristen Baer。非常感谢你们今天能来。我们来聊聊生命周期整合疗法。你们是如何使用它的？是什么让你们接触到它的？也许我们可以简单回顾一下它的历史，不用太学术化。
Yeah, so I was brought to using lifespan integration just through my own healing journey. It was something for me that was really helpful and my own therapist used it with me. So once I went through it and she told me that there was a training coming to Birmingham, then I jumped right in and have been using it with my clients ever since.
是的，我接触生命周期整合疗法是因为我自己的疗愈之旅。它对我非常有帮助，我自己的治疗师也曾对我使用过。所以当我体验过之后，她告诉我伯明翰即将举办一场培训，我就立刻报名参加了，从那以后我就一直把它用在我的客户身上。
I find it to be a really helpful healing modality. I use it with somatic experiencing and it's a body focused modality. So it really complements somatic experiencing and the work that I do with my clients. And so, yeah, that's really just what brought me to it was my own healing through lifespan integration. So I actually was looking to Kristin
我觉得这是一种非常有用的疗愈方式。我把它与躯体体验疗法结合使用，它是一种以身体为中心的疗法。所以它确实与躯体体验疗法以及我与客户所做的工作相辅相成。所以，是的，让我接触到它的原因确实是我自己通过生命周期整合疗法获得的疗愈。我当时其实是在找 Kristin
to consult about one of my clients because I knew she did the lifespan integration and somatic experiencing. And so I was curious about some of that. And so I went and talked with her about one of my clients who I was thinking might really benefit from it just based on the few things that she had told me about lifespan. And when we got to talking, it turned out that my client for a reason couldn't see her. And I was like, well, maybe I could just get trained in LI and then I could do it with my client. And so then I literally went back to my office and looked up lifespan integration.
咨询我的一位客户，因为我知道她既做生命周期整合疗法，也做躯体体验疗法。我对其中的一些内容很好奇。于是我去找她谈了我的一位客户，我觉得根据她之前告诉我的关于生命周期整合疗法的一些信息，这位客户可能会从中受益。当我们谈话时，结果发现我的客户因为某种原因无法见她。我就想，也许我可以接受 LI 培训，然后我就可以亲自为我的客户做这个疗法了。于是我回到办公室，查了一下生命周期整合疗法。
And there was a training that weekend, the level one training was literally like four days after that. And so I was like, I'm just going to go for it. So I reached out to the trainer Stephanie and I signed up. I was like, hey, just going to go for it. So I reached out to the trainer Stephanie. And I signed up, I was like, Hey, last minute, can you let me in? And she was like, of course. And that was like the beginning of my journey a year ago, March to March of 24. And now I've done all four trainings and I'm totally bought in.
那个周末正好有一场培训，一级培训就在四天之后。所以我当时想，我一定要去试试。于是我联系了培训师 Stephanie 并报了名。我说，嘿，我打算豁出去了。我联系了培训师 Stephanie，报了名，我说，嘿，时间很紧，能让我参加吗？她说当然可以。那是我一年前旅程的开始，从 23 年 3 月到 24 年 3 月。现在我已经完成了全部四项培训，我完全被它折服了。
I love it. You definitely speed ran it. You were like in training every other weekend for a minute. I mean, yeah, I got the four done in a year. So it's good. It's good. It's really good. And then Pamela, what brought you into LI? What did you do first? Because you do a couple of things. You do some somatic stuff in EMDR and what did you kind of get into it? I primarily use internal family systems, but I got into Lifespan also from talking to Kristin. But more than just talking
我喜欢这个。你绝对是加速完成了。有一段时间你每隔一个周末都在参加培训。我的意思是，是的，我在一年内完成了四项培训。所以这很好，真的很好。那么 Pamela，是什么让你接触到 LI 的？你最先做的是什么？因为你做的事情有好几种。你做一些躯体方面的工作和 EMDR，你是怎么接触到它的？我主要使用内在家庭系统疗法（IFS），但我接触生命周期整合疗法也是因为和 Kristin 的交谈。但不仅仅是和她谈论
to her about it, I watched Kristin's transformation. Not intentionally. I wasn't sitting there like, waiting to see how it was. But I did kind of slowly notice Kristin gain more of a sense of self over time. And I didn't even really link it to Eli until she told me more about it. I was like, oh, that makes a lot of sense. I just watched her grow more into herself over time. It was over the span of a year and a half. I was like, okay, I need to know more about what this is and how to do this. And so I went to level one training and you have your own, what are they called? When we do the practice trainings, like while we're there. The practicums?
它，我观察到了 Kristin 的转变。不是刻意的。我并不是坐在那里等着看它效果如何。但我确实慢慢注意到 Kristin 随着时间的推移变得更有自我感了。在 Kristin 告诉我更多关于它的信息之前，我甚至没有把它和 LI 联系起来。我当时想，哦，这很有道理。我只是看着她随着时间的推移变得越来越像她自己。那是在一年半的时间里发生的。我当时想，好吧，我需要更多地了解这是什么以及如何去做。于是我参加了一级培训，你们有自己的，叫什么来着？就是我们在那里进行的练习培训。是实践课吗？
Yeah, the little practicums where we have partners and we do it for each other in real time. And I mean, it was very powerful. And so I decided to go into level two. And I love it. I really love it. I've noticed a lot within myself and my own LI experience with my therapist. And it's kind of led me to want to continue doing it with my clients. Well, thank you for going through y'all's history with it. I'd like to back up just a second in case people aren't terribly familiar with lifespan integration. So when this is what's interesting, like when Taproot started, like we were, there was one other place that did brain spotting, like somewhere in
是的，就是那些小型的实践课，我们有搭档，实时为彼此进行练习。我的意思是，这非常有力量。所以我决定进入二级培训。我喜欢它。在我和我的治疗师进行的 LI 体验中，我对自己有了很多发现。这促使我想要继续在我的客户身上使用它。好吧，谢谢你们分享你们的经历。我想稍微倒退一下，以防大家对生命周期整合疗法不太熟悉。有趣的是，当 Taproot 刚成立时，还有另一个地方做脑点疗法，就在亨茨维尔的某个地方，但我认为她甚至不太愿意做。我曾打电话询问，但她不喜欢这种疗法。但当我们开业时，我们确定了所有这些正在兴起的大脑疗法。其中之一是 IFS，一个是躯体体验疗法，一个是生命周期整合疗法，一个是脑点疗法。还有一个是 QEG 脑图和迷走神经刺激。我们还研究了很多微量营养，因为我觉得商业化还没有完全成熟，但研究表明这些东西即将产生变革。这些就是我们认为的后 CBT 范式，将会发展起来。
Huntsville, but I think she wouldn't even really do it. Like I'd called and tried to ask and she didn't like the modality, but when we opened, we kind of identified all of these brain-based medicines that were emerging. One of them was IFS, one of them was somatic experiencing, one of them was lifespan integration, one of them was brain spotting. And then one of them was QEG brain mapping, polyvagal stimulation. And we also looked at like micronutrition a whole lot because I felt like the commercialization wasn't really there yet, but the research was kind of saying these things were about to kind of be transformative. And those were like the models that we really saw as like kind of the post CBT paradigm that was gonna grow.
所以当时并没有多少做脑点疗法的人。现在有很多了。但如果你看看治疗领域中正在增长的东西，LI 就是其中之一。我没法谈论它。我读过那本书，但当我向别人谈论这本书时，他们是 LI 培训师。
And so at that point, there weren't really any brain spotting people around. Now there's a ton. But if you look at things that are growing in therapy, I mean, LI is one of the big ones. I can't talk about it. I've read the book, but then when I talk to people about the book, they're LI trainers.
他们会说，不，不，不，别读那本书。那本书太老了，现在已经不对了。LI 是一个全新的东西，你必须参加培训才能了解它。Peggy Pace 是创始人，她在 21 世纪初，也就是 2001 年或 2002 年发明了它。这是一个协作的过程。有很多人帮助她，
They're like, no, no, no, don't read the book. The book's actually so old that it's wrong now. And LI is like this whole new thing and you have to do the training to know about it. But Peggy Pace is the founder and she invented in the early 2000s, like 2001 or two. And then it's a collaborative thing. There were tons of people kind of help her
她也在反思这个过程，它改变了很多。所以有很多炼金术式的过程，你知道，你弄清楚了什么有效以及为什么有效。现在有一些技术与 2000 年时的情况大不相同，但这是一个非常有活力、活跃的社区。我的意思是，当你遇到 LI 的人时，他们不会说，
and she's like reflecting on the process and it changes quite a bit. So there's a lot of alchemization where, you know, like you figure out what's working and why it works. And then there's some techniques that are pretty different than what's going on in 2000 now, but it's a very vibrant, active community. I mean, when you meet LI people, they're not like,
哦，是的，我做 LI，让我在会议上买个百吉饼。他们非常兴奋地和你谈论它。我认为它是那种新兴且不断增长的模式之一，它确实利用了这种基于大脑的技巧来改变我们大脑感知时间、创伤和躯体能量的方式，就像我们在 Taproot 所做的所有其他模式一样，比如我喜欢的东西。
oh yeah, I do LI, let me get a bagel at the conference. They're like really excited to talk to you about it. And I think that it's one of the kind of emerging and growing models that does do this kind of brain-based trick to change the way that our brains perceive time and trauma and somatic energy, like all of the other kinds of models that we do at Taproot, like the stuff that I like
虽然我不做它，但我已经在患者身上看到了这一点。我也看到它产生了与脑点疗法不同的效果。我见过做部分工作（如内在家庭系统疗法、对话疗法或过程导向疗法）的人，他们也尝试了 LI，他们会说，好吧，这是我从这个中学到的，这是我从那个中学到的，你知道，我看到他们以协作的方式受益。你们都是综合型从业者。所以，如果有人是提供者，想问“我为什么要接受 LI 培训”，或者患者想问“我为什么要寻找 LI 提供者”，你们能谈谈吗？这如何融入更大的疗愈范式？它与我做的其他疗法有什么不同？或者它如何融入更大的体系中？
even though I don't do it I've seen that with patients like and I've also seen it have a different effect than when you do brain spotting I've seen people who do parts work you know internal family systems or voice dialogue or process oriented therapy or something and then they also try Li and they're like well this is what I got out of this and this is what I got out of that you know I see them kind of collaboratively benefit. You guys are all kind of integrative practitioners. So could you say a little bit, you know, if somebody is a provider being like, why should I get trained in LI or a patient being like, why should I seek out an LI provider? You know, how does this fit into like a bigger paradigm of healing? You know, what does it do that is different than another kind of therapy that I do? Or, you know, how does it fit into like a kind of bigger thing?
你想按 Marie、Kristen、Pamela 的顺序来谈谈你们使用它的方式吗？因为你们都是不同的从业者，做着一种非标准但属于技术的模式。我交给你们了。我的办公室经常断视频。所以，是的，绝对。我喜欢使用生命周期整合疗法有几个原因。
You want to just kind of go in order from Marie, Kristen, Pamela, and then go through all those, the ways that you use it. Cause y'all are all different practitioners, you know, doing a model that is not standard, but you know, it's a technique. I'll turn it over to you. I lose video in my office all the time. So yeah, absolutely. I love using lifespan integration for a couple of reasons.
我接受培训的第一个基于大脑和身心的干预措施是脑点疗法。所以我非常投入，它真的很棒。我看到我与客户进行的脑点疗法会议带来了很好的疗愈效果。正如 Pamela 所说，即使是在脑点疗法的实践培训中，我个人的体验也非常棒。所以我确实很投入，现在依然如此。我仍然认为它是一个很好的工具，但我不得不说，我发现生命周期整合疗法对我的许多客户来说似乎更容易耐受，因为我的大多数客户都有严重的终身复杂创伤问题。
So I was the first brain-based, brain-body-based medicine intervention, if you will, that I was trained in was brain spotting. And so I was really into that and it was really awesome. I had seen some great healing happen as a result of the brain spawning sessions that I did with clients. And as Pamela was saying too, even just in the trainings for brain spawning in the practicums, my own personal experiences were pretty great. And so I was definitely into that and I still am. I still think it's a great tool, but I will say that I have found that lifespan integration seems to be a lot more tolerable for some of a lot of my clients because most of my clients have had severe lifelong complex
他们确实在生命周期中经历了很多。不是双关语。所以对于脑点疗法，你知道，对某些人来说，这在情感上可能会非常令人不知所措。所以我发现，对于那些不太能耐受脑点疗法的客户，因为我有一些现有的客户尝试过脑点疗法，但感觉不太舒服。
trauma issues. They've just really experienced a lot in their lifespan. No pun intended. And so with the brain spotting, you know, it can be very emotionally overwhelming for some people. And so I have found that with my clients that really did not tolerate brain spitting well because I had a number of existing clients who had tried brain spitting and just weren't super comfortable with it.
然后当我接受了 LI 培训时，我刚开始就和我的现有客户谈过，我说，嘿，你想试试这个吗？他们基本上都持开放态度。所以这就是我开始在之前尝试过脑点疗法的人身上使用它的原因。它确实被我的一些客户更好地接受了。有些人仍然更喜欢脑点疗法。这只是有一些区别。但对于 LI，我认为我经常把它描述为一个更温和的过程。脑点疗法可能会稍微刺耳一点，在情感上稍微令人不知所措一点。
And then when I got trained in LI, like right at the beginning, I just talked to my existing clients about it and I was like, hey, you want to give this a shot? And they were all pretty much open to it. And so that was when I started to try it with people who had tried brain-spitting before. And it definitely was received a lot better by some of my clients. Some people still prefer brain-spotting. There's just some differences. But with the LI, it's more of a gentle process, I think, is the way I often describe it. Brain-spotting can be a little bit more jarring, a little bit more overwhelming emotionally.
而在生命周期整合疗法中，目标始终是让某人进入他们的耐受窗口，并让他们保持在耐受窗口内，这样他们就能够耐受任何出现的情绪反应。所以，LI 是一种温和的大脑神经网络重连，而不会让客户再次受到创伤，我认为这非常棒。所以我们能够承认过去发生的事情，并以一种类似于脑点疗法和 EMDR 等基于大脑和身体的治疗方式来重新处理它们。但这看起来更温和，如果可以的话，是一条更柔和的道路。这就是我对此的看法。
Whereas in life-spending integration, the goal is always to get somebody into their window of tolerance and keep them in the window of tolerance so they're able to tolerate whatever emotional response is coming up. And so, LI is sort of a gentle re-networking of the neural network in the brain without re-traumatizing clients, which I think has been really great. So we get to acknowledge the things that have happened in the past and reprocess them in a way that is similar to the brain and body based treatments like brain spotting and EMDR. But it just seems gentler, a softer path if you will. So that's all I got on that one.
所以，是的，生命周期整合疗法确实补充了许多治疗模式。我觉得你可以把它用在大多数客户身上。就像 Marie 说的，我的很多客户确实有复杂创伤。LI 治疗的第一阶段是关于稳定化。所以它确实是为进行一些更深层的工作建立一个非常好的基础。它可以帮助客户扩大他们的耐受窗口，
So yeah, lifespan, it really complements a lot of therapy modalities. I feel like you can use it with most clients. And like Marie said, a lot of my clients, they do have complex trauma. And the first stage of LI therapy is about stabilization. So it's really about building a really great foundation for doing some of the deeper work. And it can create, it can help the client to expand their window of tolerance
或者有更多的能力去处理一些可能出现的更深层次的问题。对于生命周期整合疗法，我的意思是，你真的可以用它来解决创伤。你也可以用它来加强你的核心自我，更深入地了解你为什么做你所做的事情，你可能拥有的一些行为，你可能持有的信念，以及你为维护这些信念而采取的策略。所以这是一种非常有洞察力的疗法，我认为它与其他模式的区别在于临床医生与客户之间的协调一致。
or have more capacity to be with some of the deeper rooted things that might come up. And with lifespan, I mean, really, you can use it for trauma resolution. You can also use it to strengthen your core self, gain more insight into why you do the things you do, some of the behaviors you may have, the beliefs you may hold, the strategies that you do to uphold those beliefs. And so it's a really insightful therapy and something that I think differentiates it from some other modalities is the importance
临床医生在客户探索这些不同协议时，会以一种协调、调节的存在状态陪伴他们。我们的工作确实只是支持客户，为客户留出空间，给客户一种被关心、被支持的体验，我们与客户保持一致，并注意客户是否在他们的耐受窗口内。然后这会告知我们如何执行协议。所以我们可能会增加节奏或使用一定数量的记忆线索。
of attunement with the clinician. So the clinician is in attuned regulated presence for the client as they explore these different protocols. And our job is really just to hold the client, hold space for the client, give the client the experience of being cared for, held, we attune ourselves to our clients and notice like is our client within their window of tolerance. And then that informs us on how we do the protocols. So we might increase pacing or use a certain number of memory cues.
它还有一点非常美妙，那就是它真正基于依恋理论。所以它确实，你知道，它基于我们都有疗愈能力的知识，因为我们可能有混乱型、回避型或焦虑型依恋，但这并不意味着我们必须永远保持那种依恋风格。我们实际上可以进入一种习得性安全依恋的状态，而这正是生命周期整合疗法的所有目标。
And something else that's really beautiful about it is it's really based on attachment theory. So it really, you know, it's like with the knowledge that we all have the capacity to heal that because we may have disorganized or avoidant attachment or anxious attachment, it doesn't mean that we have to have that attachment style forever. We can actually move into a place of earned secure attachment and that is the whole goal of lifespan integration therapy.
所以这确实是一种非常美丽的模式，特别是对于那些有依恋创伤的人来说。每当我提到创伤时，我的意思是，我们很多人甚至在进入治疗时都会想，好吧，我有一个很棒的童年，你知道，我的父母提供了足够好的照顾。创伤并不总是关于你没有得到什么。有时它是关于那些没有发生的好的事情。所以我们使用这种模式只是为了探索，探索生命周期，它的整个基础被称为基线时间线。它引导你
So it's really just a beautiful modality, especially for those who have had attachment trauma. And whenever I say trauma, I mean, a lot of us may even come into therapy thinking, well, I had a great childhood, you know, like I had clients who are parents who provided good enough care. And trauma isn't always about what you didn't get. It's sometimes about, you know, the good things that didn't happen. So we just use this modality really just to explore, explore the lifespan and the whole basis of it is what's called the baseline timeline. And it walks you
从你生命的第一天一直到今天。它让你扎根于当下的安全感中。所以这确实是创伤治疗的目标，即在当下创造更多的安全感。这就是生命周期整合疗法所做的。我们总是以当下时间结束。这就是我的看法以及我如何将其用于我的客户。正如我之前所说，我接受过躯体体验疗法的培训。我已经完成了所有的培训，它们互补得非常好，因为
through day one of your life all the way through present day. And it grounds you and the safety of the present time. So that's really the goal of trauma therapy is to create more safety in the presence. And that's what lifespan does. We always end in present time. So that's just my take on it and how I use it with my clients. And like I said before, I am trained in somatic experiencing. I've been through all the trainings and they complement each other so well because
它们都是非常、非常温和的模式。就像 Marie 说的，你知道，这是关于不造成二次创伤。所以甚至不需要重新经历创伤。很多客户不想谈论他们的创伤经历。生命周期整合疗法的魅力在于，他们只需要告诉你一个短语，他们的大脑就会围绕他们告诉你的短语进行组织。它创造了这些神经网络的重组，实际上在客户系统中创造了更多的稳定性和平静。它的好处是令人难以置信的。我在我的客户身上看到了这一点。所以
they're just both very, very gentle modalities. Like Maria was saying, you know, it's about not re-traumatizing. So not even having to live back through the trauma. A lot of clients don't want to have to talk about their traumatic experiences. And the beauty of lifespan integration is that they can just tell you a phrase and their brain is going to organize around the phrase that they're telling you. And it creates this reorganization of these neural networks that actually creates a lot more stabilization and peace in the client system. And it's, it's the benefits are they're incredible. I've seen it with my clients. So
Pamela，你能谈谈这如何与你的工作整合吗？你可能是更多基于部分工作的从业者，类似于我喜欢的后荣格学派的东西。所以这就是我正在做的。你能谈谈 LI 是如何插入到任何这些基于部分的结构中的吗？是的，这很有趣，因为它与 IFS 搭配得非常好，特别是对于那些不太想说话的客户。
and Pamela, can you talk about how that integrates with your work? You may be one of the more parts based people, similar to the, you know, I like the post union stuff. So that's what I'm doing. Can you talk maybe a little bit about how LI plugs into any of those kind of parts based structures? Yeah, it's interesting because it pairs really well with IFS, particularly for clients who don't really want to talk a lot.
在 IFS 中，也没有太多的谈话，但生命周期整合疗法在这一点上非常独特。就像 Kristin 说的，你只需要提供一个短语。它确实帮助了那些经常与不知所措感作斗争的客户，因为它有助于一次解决一小部分情绪，而不是深入研究任何特定的创伤。所以，LI 的另一个好处是它不会跳入躯体方面，而我们的创伤显然是在身体里的。所以……所以它不治疗躯体创伤，但你觉得……
And IFS, there's also not a whole lot of talking, but lifespan is just so unique in that way. Like Kristin said, you can just offer a phrase. And it really helps clients who struggle with overwhelm a lot because it helps to resolve little pieces of emotion at a time versus kind of diving into any one particular trauma. So well, and the other great thing about LI is it doesn't jump into somatic stuff, which is obviously where our trauma is, is in the body. And so... So it doesn't treat somatic trauma, but you feel like...
不，但是……你说它不会跳入那个领域。你能稍微解析一下吗？是的。它像 Kristin 说的那样，从建立更多的基础开始，到你可以……稍后在第三阶段，我相信 Kristin 可能能帮我，那时你开始更多地进入身体实际持有的东西。但首先，它解决诸如你如何应对创伤、你对自己、他人和世界持有什么信念等问题。
No, but... You say how it doesn't jump into that. Can you maybe parse that a little bit? Yeah. It starts, like Kristin said, with building more of a foundation to where you can then... Later on the third stage, I believe, Kristin might be able to help me with this, is when you start to go more into what the body is actually holding. But first, it addresses things like how you've coped with the trauma, what beliefs you hold about yourself and others in the world.
一旦建立了这种安全感，你就可以深入到你的身体正在持有所有这些东西的地方。Kristin，你能帮忙吗？我——是的，绝对。是的，我认为第二阶段、第三阶段通常是我们开始更多地进入身体的时候。对于很多进来的客户，
And once that safety is established, then you can go kind of deeper into where your body is holding all of this stuff. Kristin, can you help? I- Yeah, definitely. Yeah, I think stage two, stage three are typically where we start to get more into the body. For a lot of clients that come in,
他们真的在自己的头脑里。所以这就是他们过度理智化的地方，很多进来的客户真的在自己的头脑里。所以这就是他们过度理智化很多，你知道，有点更解离。这就是为什么 LI 对他们来说是一个很好的治疗方法，因为，你知道，它可以是，好吧，看，我知道身体对你来说不是一个安全的地方。所以让我们从这里开始，建立更多的基础，建立那个耐受窗口。我们不必现在就进入身体。然后当你走向 LI 工作的第二阶段时，那就是你开始更多地关注身体感觉和出现的感觉的时候。当他们听到这些，
they're really in their heads. So that's where they over-intellectualize a lot of clients that come in, they're really in their heads. So that's where they over intellectualize a lot, you know, kind of more dissociative. And that's what makes a lie a really good, a good treatment for them is because, you know, it can be like, okay, look, I know the body hasn't been a safe place for you to be. So let's just start here here building more of a foundation, building up that window of tolerance. We don't have to go into the body just yet. And then as you move toward the stage two of LI work, that's where you start to kind of pay more attention to the body sensations and the felt sense of what's coming up. As they hear there,
这些不同的协议。所以你可能会注意到，嘿，你知道，你注意到了什么？你注意到紧张了吗？你注意到当你听到这个时你感觉更放松了吗？这通常会自然地出现在客户身上。所以我上周甚至有一位客户，距离他们上次听到自己的时间线已经有一段时间了。一旦他们听到时间线的重复，他们说，你知道，这感觉真是一种解脱。已经有一段时间了，你知道，我感觉更平静了。这通常是我们结束会议的地方。
these different protocols. So you might notice like, hey, you know, what are you noticing? Do you notice tension? Do you notice that you feel more relaxed when you hear this? And often that comes up organically for clients. So I even had a client last week who had been a little while since they had heard their timeline. And once they heard the repetition of their timeline, they said, you know, that feels like such a relief. It's been a while, you know, I feel just like calmer. And that's often where we end our sessions.
我们希望在客户感觉比刚来时稍微好一点的时候结束会议。所以这就是我们在执行这些协议时所监测的内容。就像每次重复一样，在时间线重复之后，我们休息一下，然后问，你注意到了什么？有时是，哦，我感到更焦虑了，
We want to end our sessions where our client feels just a little bit better than they did when they came in. So that's really what we're monitoring as we do these protocols. It's like with each repetition, after the timeline repetition, we take a break and it's, what are you noticing? And sometimes that's, oh, I'm feeling more anxious
或者，哦，我感到更平静了。所以我们只是，你知道，顺其自然，然后根据客户调整我们的治疗。我认为这是 LI 与许多治疗模式不同的另一点，它对我们客户的神经系统非常可定制。就像我们，当我们的客户进来进行评估时，我们正在评估，你知道，这个客户，
or, oh, I'm feeling calmer. So we just kind of, you know, go with that and then mold our treatment to the client. And that's something else I think that differentiates LI from a lot of therapy modalities is it's so customizable to our clients' nervous systems. Like we, when our clients come in for an intake and we are assessing, you know, is this client,
我们有不同类型的客户，比如类型一、类型二、类型三，这在评估部分会更深入一些，但我们正在了解，好吧，我们的客户在他们的耐受窗口中处于什么位置？他们大部分时间都在耐受窗口内吗？还是根本不在？他们大部分时间处于交感神经状态，
we have different types of clients, like type one, type two, type three, and that's going a little deeper into some of the assessment piece, but we're kind of getting a sense of, okay, where is our client in their window of tolerance? Are they in the window of tolerance most of the time? None of the time? Are they in more of a sympathetic state a lot of the time
还是副交感神经状态？我们需要帮助上调他们的神经系统进入窗口，还是下调神经系统？我们如何创造更多的能力和容量来保持在那个窗口内？所以，所以是的，我们只是根据我们的客户调整这些协议，并确定他们需要什么。正如我所说，在第一阶段，它不是关于身体的，我们实际上很快就通过了这一阶段，我们并没有试图进入身体。所以对于一些非常在头脑里的客户来说，这让它感觉更安全，因为身体并不是一个非常安全的地方。
or a parasympathetic state? Do we need to help up-regulate their nervous system into the window or down-regmpathetic state? Do we need to help up regulate their nervous system into the window or down regulate the nervous system? Like how can we create more, more ability and capacity to be within that window? So, so yeah, we just mold these protocols to our clients and determine what it is that they need. And like I said, in the first stage, it's not about body, we actually move through this pretty quickly, and we're not trying to get into the body. And so it makes it feel a little safer to some of our clients who are very much in their heads, because the body hasn't been a very safe place to be.
当我听到人们谈论生命周期整合疗法时，我看到的一件事是，你知道，它是关于一个连贯的生活叙事，你正在使用叙事作为一种方式来深入创伤事件之下。但当很多人想到叙事疗法时，他们想到的是叙事，老派的那种叙事疗法，有很多日记，你有一本大书，你把生活中的所有事件用线连在板子上，或者你做一棵树，果实是好的东西，而这些是树围绕生长的坏伤口。还有所有这些手工练习，而 LI 的工作方式并不完全是那样。它更多的是让你体验你对时间的感知。
And one of the things that I've seen when I hear people talk about lifespan is that, you know, it's about a coherent life narrative that you're kind of using narrative as this way to get sort of like under a traumatic event. But when a lot of people think of narrative therapy, they're thinking of the narrative, the old school kind of like narrative therapy, where there's a lot of journaling and you've got a big book and you have all the events with your life connected with strings on a board or you do the tree where the fruit is the good stuff. And these are the bad wounds that the tree grew around. And there's all these kind of arts and crafts exercises, whereas LA doesn't quite work like that. It's a little bit more of making you experience your perception of time.
我从患者那里听到的一些关于他们与其他提供者进行 LI 的时间的事情听起来几乎像艾瑞克森催眠，就像其中的一部分，你有点真正遇到了这些早期的自我部分。你能谈谈叙事在 LI 实践中如何超越时间、疗愈创伤吗？
Some of the stuff that I've heard patients tell me about their time in LI with other providers sounded almost like ericsonia hypnosis, like parts of it, where you're kind of like really encountering these earlier parts of self. Could you talk about the use of narrative to kind of transcend time, heal trauma in the practice of LI?
有人对此有什么反思吗？是的，我可以。正如 Kristin 所说，我们在 LI 治疗中使用时间线，所以它确实是你生活的故事，它有点像是在看你生活的电影，但我们看的是你生活的精彩片段。所以与其试图把你的生活经历的每一个细节都塞进一个长长的连续故事中，我们使用所谓的“时间线”，时间线由所谓的“记忆线索”组成。
Anyone have any kind of reflections on that Yeah, I can so with the as Kristen was kind of talking about like so we use timelines and Li therapy and so it's not it is a story of your life and it's kind of like it's like watching a movie of your life But we're kind of looking at highlight reels of your life and it's kind of like it's like watching a movie of your life but we're kind of looking at highlight reels so rather than trying to get every detail of your life experiences into one long consecutive story we use what's called a timeline and the timeline is composed of what are called memory cues and so memory cues are one to a few words that remind somebody of a specific
所以记忆线索是一个到几个词，提醒某人特定的时间点，特定的记忆。所以通过建立这些时间线，时间线字面上由这些线索组成，而不是关于过去经历的额外信息或更多细节。所以发生的事情是，例如，当我们做基线时间线时，就像 Kristin 谈到的那样，所以我们会选择，我们从发展线索开始。
point in time a specific memory if you. And so in building those timelines, the timeline is literally consisting of those cues and not like additional information or more detail about the experiences in the past. And so what happens is, for example, when we were doing the baseline timeline, like Kristen was talking about, so we would pick, we start with developmental cues. we were doing the baseline timeline, like Kristen was talking about. So we would pick, we start with developmental cues.
所以最初在基线时间线中，你从你出生一天大开始。所以显然我们不记得我们一天大时的情况，但我们相信并知道，身体和大脑对那种经历有记忆，即使你没有明确的记忆。所以我们为最初的几天、最初的几年使用发展线索，
So initially with the baseline timeline, you're starting with like, you're one day old. So obviously we don't remember when we're one day old, but we believe and know that like the body and the brain have memory of that experience, even though you don't have like an explicit memory of it. So we start with developmental cues for those first days, first few years,
因为大多数人在两到四岁、两到三岁之前没有明确的记忆。所以从第一个明确的记忆或某人能够有意识地回忆并告诉自己或他人关于它的记忆开始，我们为整个生命中的每一年至少做一个线索。然后你最多可以有三个。所以生命中的每一年必须至少有一个线索，最多三个在他们生命中那一年发生的经历。所以，你知道，如果我们有一个人，你知道，在 60 多岁，这是一个更长的时间线，因为我们有 60 年的经历。而自然地，年纪较轻的人，他们的时间会短一点。
because most people don't have explicit memories until around age two to four, two to three. So then from the first explicit memory or memory that somebody's able to consciously recall and tell themselves or others about, we do at least one cue per year for the entire year or life. And then you can have up to three. So each year of the life has to have at least one queue, up to three experiences that occurred in their life in that year of their life. So, you know, if we've got somebody who's, you know, in their 60s, it is a longer timeline because we've got 60 years of experiences. Whereas naturally speaking, somebody who's younger, their time is going to be a little shorter. naturally speaking, somebody's younger, their comments
但实际上，这只是关于包含各种记忆。所以我们喜欢平衡生活的故事，包含积极、消极和中性的记忆或线索。所以我们想包含那些非常有影响力和意义的经历，以便它们可以开始被重新处理。但我们也想在人们的生活中包含积极的经历。我们开始建立 Kristin 也谈到的那个连贯自我的方式之一，就是识别人们经历过的积极事物，特别是当我们主要与那些经历过很多沉重事物的人一起工作时，
can be a little shorter. But really, it's just about including a variety of memories too. So we kind of like to balance the story of the life without with, you know, positive, negative and neutral memories or cues. So we want to include experiences that were very impactful and significant, so that those can start to be reprocessed. But we also want to include just positive experiences in people's life. One of the ways that we can start to build that cohesive self that Kristen was also talking about is identifying the positive things that people have experienced, especially when people who we're working with predominantly have a lot of heavy stuff that
那些不舒服或带来不舒服感觉、情绪或想法的事情。能够结合积极的经历真的很好。这实际上是我在客户治疗计划中列出的内容之一，如果我们要致力于建立改进的自我感，提高自尊，那就是结合积极的经历，他们坚强、能够为自己挺身而出或有良好人际互动的经历，这样我们就能得到一个更平衡的生活故事。
they've been through and that's uncomfortable or brings up uncomfortable feelings or emotions or thoughts. It's really nice to be able to incorporate positive experiences. That's actually one of the things I have on my treatment plans with my clients is if we're working on building an improved sense of self, raising self-esteem is tying in positive experiences, experiences where they were strong and, you know, were able to stand up for themselves or, you know, had good interpersonal interactions, you know, just so we can get more of a balanced story of the life.
所以，我的意思是，最终，我认为这就是区别。就像我说的，它是特定的时间点，而不是带有所有细节的整个故事。我还要说，它们都是，而且作为客户，我也是 LI 的接受者。所以，当我们经历这些时间线时，更多的记忆会出现。所以当我解释生命周期整合疗法时，很多人会说的一件事是，哦，天哪，我不记得我 12 岁时发生了什么。我怎么能想出一个记忆线索？好吧，我们可以使用你生活中一些比较广泛的经历点。所以理想的线索就像我说的，是一个非常特定的时间点，你可以
So that's, I mean, ultimately, I think it's the differences. Like I said, it's specific points in time, not the entire story with all the details. I will say too, they're both and I also am recipient as a client of LI. And so like, as we're going through those timelines, more memories present. So one of the things that a lot of people will say when I explain lifespan integration is like, oh my gosh, I can't remember like what happened when I was 12. How am I going to come up with a memory cue? Well, we can use certain points in your life experiences that are pretty a little bit more broad. So the ideal cue is going to be like I said, a very specific moment in time that you can
记住，但它也可以是你的第一位老师是谁，或者你住在黄房子里。因为有些人确实因为各种原因无法获得更详细的记忆，特别是在对他们的小系统来说非常创伤的时期。所以这也是我们可以做的事情，我们可以使用更广泛的线索，但时间线始终是一个灵活的文档。它是一个活的文件。我们可以更改它，更新它。我们可以重新措辞特定的线索。
remember, but it can also be here first grade teacher was, or that you lived in the yellow house. Because some people really aren't able to access more detailed memories for various reasons, especially in times that were very traumatic for them, for their little systems to hold. And so that is also something we get to do is like we can use more broad, but the timeline is always, it's a, I would say it's a flexible document. It's a living document. We can change it, update it. We can reword specific cues.
我们可以删除线索。我们可以添加线索来真正捕捉他们生活的完整叙事。以一种对他们有帮助的方式。所以这就像是，即使他们不记得生命中某个年龄或某个时间的事情，通常在会议中听到时间线和我们所做的重复，也会开始扩展其中一些有意识的记忆，将更多的东西带入他们的意识。而且，你知道，很多人提到的 LI 所做的事情之一是整合不同的自我部分，你有不同种类的极端反应或不同的极端自我部分，它们相处不来或看不到彼此的价值。Kristin，你能谈谈你看到这种整合的方式，或者你看到这些自我部分变得更像民主，而不是为了争夺汽车方向盘而打架的碎片吗？
We can take out cues. We can add cues to really capture that full narrative of their life. In a way that is helpful to them. And so that would just be like the thing too, is like that even if they don't remember something from a certain age or certain time in their lives, like usually hearing the timeline and sessions and the repetitions that we do will start to expand some of those conscious memories to bring more to their awareness as well. And, you know, one of the things that a lot of people bring up as part of what LA does is integrate different parts of self, that you have different kind of extreme reactions or different extreme parts of self that don't get along or don't kind of see the value of each other. Christian, could you say anything about the way that you see that integrate or the way
你如何看待它在治疗中起作用？是的，嗯，你知道，关于 LI，人们说它是关于在时间中编织自我状态。人们经常看到，哦，当我反思我的生活时，感觉好像有不同版本的我，我活了三次，三种不同的生活，你知道，所以人们能够反思这一点，并开始把所有这些整合在一起。在一个人的一生中可能会发生很多碎片化，这些我们的一部分被困在这些创伤事件中，或者只是在我们生活中的不同时间，
that you see those parts of self sort of become more of a democracy and less of, you know, pieces fighting for the wheel of a car in the van. Um, you know, how do you see that, um, work and therapy? Yeah, well, um, you know, they say about Eli that it's about weaving ego states through time. And often people do see like, oh, as I reflect on my life, it feels like there's different versions of me that I've lived three different times, three different lives, you know, and so people are able to reflect on that and kind of start to bring all of it together. There's a lot of fragmentation that can happen over the course of someone's life and these parts of us that get stuck in these traumatic events or just in different times
发生了某些事情，比如父母离婚、你自己的离婚、车祸之类的。所以我们正在做的是帮助把所有这些碎片连接在一起，创造那个更连贯的生活叙事。我告诉我的客户，这就像，想象一个拼图游戏刚刚被扔在房间里，碎片散落在各处，我们并没有真正连贯的自我感。我们并不真正知道所有这些碎片是如何连接起来并把我带到现在的，所以这就是我们正在做的，一次拼凑一个碎片。
in our lives where there was something that happened like a parent's divorce or your own divorce or a car accident or something like that. And so what we're doing is helping to connect all of these pieces together and create that more coherent life narrative. And I tell my clients, it's like, imagine a jigsaw puzzle has just been thrown across the room and there's pieces here and there and we don't really have a coherent sense of self. We don't really know like how did all these pieces connect and bring me to where I am now and so that's what we're doing like piecing things together one at a
当你在这个客户系统中创造更多的连贯性时，这些部分就开始更多地协同工作。所以这是关于整合。这不是关于部分的隔离。更多的是把它们全部带到一起，创造一个更坚实的核心自我。这就是我们所做的一些工作，我们正在探索人们持有的这些信念，你知道，我告诉人们，你不是带着这些信念来到这个世界的，它们是由其他人强加给你的，对吧。所以我们学习，我们持有的这些信念是什么，比如，不重要，或者人们听不到我说话，人们不理解
time and as you create more coherence within the client system, then these parts start to kind of work more together. So it's about the integration. It's not about the separation of parts. It's more about bringing them all together and creating a more solid core self. And that's, you know, some of that work that we do where we are exploring these beliefs that people hold, you know, I tell people, you don't come into the world with these beliefs, they're imposed on you by some other, right. So we learn like, what are these beliefs that we hold, like, unimportant, or people can't hear me, people don't understand
我。我们开始把这些信念整合到时间线中，并给人们更多关于它们的洞察。它们是什么时候开始的？这些事情是如何，我什么时候开始这样看待自己的？什么时候这些信念不一定是真的？以及我们用来维护这些信念的策略。比如，你知道，我保持渺小，我保持安静，因为别人听不到我说话。
me. And we start to integrate these beliefs into the timeline and give people just more insight around them. When did they start? How did these things, when did I start believing this about myself? And when are times that it's not necessarily true? And strategies that we use to uphold these as well. Like, you know, I stay small and I stay quiet because others can't hear me. you know, I stay small and I stay quiet because others can't hear me. And so it's really about these different parts of us that show up at different times that are protectors and we get to know these protectors also through our timelines as well. It's something we do in stage one. And these protectors are often about things we're not doing. So maybe not connecting, not moving.
所以这确实是关于我们这些在不同时间出现的不同部分，它们是保护者，我们也可以通过我们的时间线来了解这些保护者。这是我们在第一阶段所做的事情。这些保护者通常是关于我们没有做的事情。所以也许是不连接，不移动。
This is something that we start to gain more insight around, around how it's protected us through our life and form alliances with these protectors and these parts of ourselves that, you know, prevent us from being able to feel or prevent us from connecting with others. And then we can also start to get a sense of how we've survived.
这是我们开始获得更多洞察的事情，关于它如何在我们的生活中保护我们，并与这些保护者以及我们自己的这些部分形成联盟，你知道，防止我们能够感受或防止我们与他人连接。然后我们也可以开始了解我们是如何生存下来的。
And there's parts of us that have enabled that so it's really about forming alliances with the parts of ourselves and then bringing all the parts suspicious of are the ones that treat every person like they're the same or pretend like, well, once the provider has mastered this, then there's going to be this, if this, then that flow chart or formula for therapy. And then they get everybody to this place. The ones that I like a little bit more make a lot of room for the individuality and the subjectivity of the practitioner and the patient because they are more of like a lens to examine an issue or a set of techniques wrapped in kind of a controlling metaphor or something. And there's a lot in lifespan. I'm wondering if you could talk to the flexibility of it.
我们自身的一部分促成了这种情况，所以这实际上是与我们自身的各个部分结成联盟，然后将所有部分带入。那些令人怀疑的疗法，要么是把每个人都当作一样对待，要么是假装一旦治疗师掌握了这一点，就会有一套“如果这样，就那样”的流程图或治疗公式，然后他们就能把每个人都带到那个状态。我更喜欢那些为从业者和患者的个性和主观性留出很大空间的疗法，因为它们更像是一种审视问题的透镜，或者是一套包裹在某种控制性隐喻中的技术。Lifespan Integration（LI）中有很多这样的内容，我想知道你是否能谈谈它的灵活性。
Just going back to the influences, I don't think Pace was influenced by Jung or any of the post-Yugians other than maybe Schwartz because she doesn't seem to mention them. Just the word ego states in the title of the first book makes me think about transactional analysis and Eric Byrne, so that's probably sort of in the water that she's drinking. I would imagine, never heard her mention that. She does mention Schwartz and internal family systems. She talks about Dan Siegel's interpersonal neurobiology. She talks about attachment theory, which a lot of people use, you know,
回到影响因素，我不认为Pace受到荣格或任何后荣格学派的影响，除了可能受到Schwartz的影响，因为她似乎没有提到他们。仅仅是第一本书标题中的“自我状态”（ego states）这个词，就让我想到了交互分析和Eric Byrne，所以这可能就是她所处的环境。我想象是这样，但我从未听她提起过。她确实提到了Schwartz和内在家庭系统（IFS）。她谈到了Dan Siegel的人际神经生物学。她谈到了依恋理论，很多人都在使用它，你知道的，
Balbi and Ainsworth and and then memory Reconsolidation theory the fact that like these memories are overwhelming and bad until we get a theta wave until we can kind of go Into them with more compassion then they open up now We're in a place where we could modify them which is where therapy is supposed to happen and then when they come back up They're not as bad because it's about getting the trauma not avoiding the trauma Which I think cognitive therapy sometimes does or behavioral therapy can do Um, but going into the trauma in a way that is useful in the therapy room so that when it comes up in life It's not as bad
Bowlby和Ainsworth，还有记忆重组理论。事实上，这些记忆在获得theta波之前是令人难以承受且糟糕的，直到我们能以更多的同情心进入它们，它们才会打开。现在我们处于一个可以修正它们的位置，这正是治疗应该发生的地方。当它们再次浮现时，它们就不会那么糟糕了，因为关键在于面对创伤，而不是回避创伤，我认为认知疗法有时会回避，或者行为疗法可能会这样做。嗯，但要以一种在治疗室中有用的方式进入创伤，这样当它在生活中出现时，就不会那么糟糕了。
um, and it seems like li does that with playing with kind of a narratives about time in a way like eric sonian hypnosis and some of the older like i'm thinking of that eric sonian hypnosis prompt about You know go back to your room when you're a child and think of the carpet on the ground and remember, you know think of the doorknob and what the wood smelled like and Open the door and see yourself on the bed as a kid a lot of the techniques that I've heard seem similar to those things Where you're taking you know, this piece of you has to be this thing But at another time this piece of you had to be that thing now mush them together and make them fight and make them kind of figure out what the core self is. You know, that seems to be the experience of patients that I've heard that have also come to me for another kind of therapy.
嗯，LI似乎通过玩转关于时间的叙事来做到这一点，有点像艾瑞克森催眠，我想到了那个艾瑞克森催眠的提示，你知道，回到你小时候的房间，想想地上的地毯，记住，你知道，想想门把手，木头的味道，打开门，看到小时候躺在床上的自己。我听到的很多技术似乎都与这些类似，你把“你的这一部分必须是这个样子”，但在另一个时间“你的这一部分必须是那个样子”，现在把它们揉在一起，让它们打架，让它们弄清楚核心自我到底是什么。你知道，这似乎是我听到的那些也曾找我进行过其他类型治疗的患者的体验。
Anything about just the flexibility of this modality and how it kind of can hook into, you know, anybody's style, anybody's way of thinking. Well, one of the things that as you were talking just now that came up for me or what I was thinking is that although LI is pretty, what's the word, structured, regimented, like there are protocols, there is a direction for how you use the protocols, a progression of using the different protocols. But that being said, it is very much individualized per client as far as like Krista mentioned the attunement piece. So a lot of what we do as LI therapists
关于这种模式的灵活性，以及它如何能与任何人的风格、任何人的思维方式挂钩。嗯，刚才你说话的时候，我想到的一点是，虽然LI相当——怎么说呢——结构化、规范化，比如有协议，有使用协议的方向，有使用不同协议的进程。但话虽如此，就Krista提到的调谐（attunement）部分而言，它在很大程度上是针对每个客户进行个性化的。所以我们作为LI治疗师所做的大部分工作，
is be attuned to what our client system needs in that session that day. As clients seem to progress in LI therapy and get later on to like stage two and stage three work, they can be more collaborative in the process of identifying what is coming up for them, what their system is kind of telling them this week. But initially we do a lot of that sort of a tuning to them and identifying what they might benefit from.
就是调谐到我们客户的系统在那次会话中需要什么。随着客户在LI治疗中取得进展，进入第二阶段和第三阶段的工作，他们可以在识别自己身上出现的问题、他们的系统本周在告诉他们什么的过程中更加协作。但最初，我们确实做了很多那种对他们的调谐，并识别他们可能从什么中受益。
So doing different protocols, like Kristen was talking about, the protectors. And then we also have strategies, like things that we do to cope that we can sort of sense for the client. We kind of know where they are in their processing of their life experiences and what might be beneficial for them to do next. So often before they come in for their session, we're actually looking at what work we've done with them, where we went last, and what might be a good direction to go in that session that day. And then too, even once, you know, we may have a game plan, but once they enter into our office and they give us some feedback about, you know,
所以做不同的协议，就像Kristen谈到的保护者。然后我们还有策略，比如我们为客户感知到的应对方式。我们大致知道他们处于生活经历处理的哪个阶段，以及接下来对他们来说什么是有益的。所以通常在他们来参加会话之前，我们实际上是在查看我们与他们做过的工作，我们上次进展到了哪里，以及在那次会话中什么是一个好的方向。然后，即使我们可能有一个计划，但一旦他们进入我们的办公室并给我们一些反馈，关于，你知道，
what is their system experience since their last session, we might even, you know, pivot and change the game plan a little bit. So it really is about attuning to what it is that they need in that moment. But also I do appreciate that there is a structure to it. There's pretty much a path to how we proceed through the different protocols. And protocols I'm mentioning are just different timelines, different types of timelines. So we've talked about like the baseline timeline, which is like the story of the entire life. And then we have protocols for specific traumas,
自上次会话以来他们的系统体验是什么，我们甚至可能会调整和改变计划。所以这确实是关于调谐到他们那一刻所需要的东西。但我确实很欣赏它是有结构的。我们通过不同协议的路径基本上是固定的。我提到的协议只是不同的时间线，不同类型的时间线。所以我们谈到了基准时间线，就像整个生活的叙事。然后我们有针对特定创伤的协议，
like a PTSD timeline or what we call a TLAM or timeline from explicit memory. And so those are both used pretty early on in LI therapy to sort of clear out, if you will, anything that's happened or occurred in the past five years that feels unresolved or still brings up very strong emotions or maybe symptoms of PTSD around reminders or stimuli related to those events. protocol is great because we can walk through, hit the high notes of an entire experience from the beginning to end and then bring them to present time. But also the TLEM, that explicit memory timeline is very helpful because it is even gentler where we just use one cue that connects back to the event at the very end of the event, sort of like where there was an assumed level of safety, like they were able to feel some sense of safety towards the end of event and then just bring them to the present time of cues.
比如PTSD时间线，或者我们称之为TLAM，即显性记忆时间线。所以这两者在LI治疗的早期都被使用，用来清理，如果你愿意的话，过去五年中发生的任何感觉未解决或仍然带来强烈情绪，或者可能围绕与这些事件相关的提醒或刺激产生PTSD症状的事情。协议很棒，因为我们可以走一遍，抓住整个体验从开始到结束的重点，然后把他们带到当下。但TLAM，那个显性记忆时间线也非常有帮助，因为它更温和，我们只使用一个线索，连接到事件的最末端，就像那里有一种假设的安全感，比如他们在事件结束时能够感受到某种安全感，然后就把他们带到当下的线索中。
So just to throw in there a couple of protocols that we do. And then there are things that we can do later on in all eye therapy. Once there's more like emotional regulation and distress tolerance, more core self built, where we can actually go back into, you know, specific memories or experiences earlier in life. And so, I think definitely with like, it is largely based around attachment theory, and that's what I love. Ever since I heard about attachment theory, that's just really what I clung to. I really believe it. I think there's no way that we can really go through our lives expecting or believing that what we've been through in the past didn't shape us or impact us.
所以只是想补充几个我们做的协议。然后还有一些我们在LI治疗后期可以做的事情。一旦有了更多的情绪调节和痛苦耐受力，建立了更多的核心自我，我们实际上可以回到生活中更早的特定记忆或经历中。所以，我认为LI绝对在很大程度上是基于依恋理论的，这就是我所爱的。自从我听说依恋理论以来，我就一直坚持这一点。我真的相信它。我认为我们不可能真的在生活中期望或相信我们过去所经历的一切没有塑造或影响我们。
So I've always wanted to help people work on identifying what are those things and how can we readdress or how can we re-network, re-race the neural network to help no longer experience triggers related to our past experiences, which I think is very much how LI operates. These things that we have experienced across our lifespan are just so impactful and so important that they can't be ignored. They need to be integrated. There are so many pieces. If you think of it, there're just pieces hanging out in different areas and we're sort of bringing them all together to build a cohesive network, like we said, with the whole story
所以我一直想帮助人们致力于识别那些东西是什么，以及我们如何重新解决或如何重新连接、重新编织神经网络，以帮助不再经历与我们过去经历相关的触发点，我认为这非常符合LI的运作方式。我们在整个生命周期中经历的这些事情是如此具有影响力且重要，以至于它们不能被忽视。它们需要被整合。有太多的碎片。如果你想一想，它们只是散落在不同的区域，我们正在把它们全部整合在一起，建立一个连贯的网络，就像我们说的，把整个故事
of the life as being able to be held at the same place together. And so I really appreciate that because I always believed, like I said, in attachment theory and I really wanted a way to help people heal from childhood lens. And this is exactly what LI has provided me with the opportunity to do. Yeah. And to expand on that, Marie, I think
作为能够被保持在同一个地方。所以我真的很感激这一点，因为我一直相信，就像我说的，依恋理论，我真的想要一种方法来帮助人们从童年的创伤中治愈。而这正是LI为我提供的机会。是的。为了扩展这一点，Marie，我认为
something that I really love about LI is that it really does honor the client's autonomy. So the client does have a say. And they can choose how much that they share with us and what they want to work on. And we as the attuned clinicians, you know, we kind of gain a sense and we guide our clients along the way. But as they progress through the stages of LI therapy, and they gain more insight, and
我非常喜欢LI的一点是，它确实尊重客户的自主权。所以客户确实有发言权。他们可以选择分享多少，以及他们想处理什么。而我们作为调谐的临床医生，你知道，我们获得了一种感觉，并引导我们的客户一路走来。但随着他们在LI治疗阶段的进展，他们获得了更多的洞察力，并且
they are able to be more assertive and know what it is that they need, and they are able to be more assertive and know what it is that they need. And they are able to kind of say, hey, yeah, I think that this is what I need today. And then they can become more involved in the process. And, you know, I just think because it's so client centered and adaptable to every single client that we have, it's not just a, you know, one size fits all approach. We can, you know, come in and set and hold space for our clients and kind of get a sense of what it is that they need and until they're able to do that on their own.
他们能够更加自信，知道自己需要什么。他们能够说，嘿，是的，我想这就是我今天需要的。然后他们可以更多地参与到这个过程中。而且，你知道，我只是认为因为它非常以客户为中心，并且可以适应我们拥有的每一个客户，它不仅仅是一种“一刀切”的方法。我们可以进来，为我们的客户设定并保持空间，并大致了解他们需要什么，直到他们能够自己做到这一点。
So, yeah, I think it's a really beautiful modality and that it can be adapted in any way that it's needed for each client. And you can use certain protocols and not go through all the stages of LI therapy if that's not what's right for the client at the time. You can resolve relationship wounds with relationship protocol.
所以，是的，我认为这是一种非常美丽的模式，它可以以每位客户所需的任何方式进行调整。如果这对当时的客户不合适，你可以使用某些协议，而不必经历LI治疗的所有阶段。你可以用关系协议来解决关系创伤。
You can work on PTSD events with the PTSD protocol. You can just work on forming these alliance with the protectors with adding in some baseline pluses and, and just giving the client a general sense of, yeah, this is my life and this is what has happened and it's led me to where I am now. And now I am here and I am safe where I'm at now. And yeah, a lot of negative things have happened, but also a lot of positive things have happened. And overall, I've survived. I'm here. And that's really what I hear a lot from my clients is like, oh, wow. Yeah. We're really, really good at orienting toward the negative. In SC, we call it the trauma vortex. It has a very strong pull. And we often really want to focus on
你可以用PTSD协议来处理PTSD事件。你也可以只通过添加一些基准加法来与保护者形成联盟，并给客户一种普遍的感觉，即“是的，这就是我的生活，这就是发生过的事情，它把我带到了现在的位置。现在我在这里，我在我现在所处的地方是安全的。”是的，发生了很多负面的事情，但也发生了很多积极的事情。总的来说，我活下来了。我在这里。这确实是我从客户那里听到很多的话，就像，“哦，哇。”是的。我们非常、非常擅长向负面倾斜。在SC中，我们称之为创伤漩涡。它有一种非常强的拉力。我们通常真的想专注于
these negative things because that's what keeps us safe. If we're hyperv strong pull and we often really want to focus on these negative things because that's what keeps us safe, right? Like if we're hypervigilant and we are aware of the negatives, then we can avoid those things or we can protect ourselves from those things. And so what we want to do in building capacity is build more capacity to be with the joy, be with the good things that have happened. And so that does help to integrate both of those things like, yeah, these bad things have happened, but look at how I survived it. Look at how I'm still here. Look at these really intelligent ways that my nervous
这些负面的事情，因为那是让我们保持安全的东西。如果我们过度警觉，并且意识到负面因素，那么我们就可以避免这些事情，或者我们可以保护自己免受这些事情的伤害。所以我们在建立能力时想要做的是，建立更多的能力来与快乐共处，与发生的好事共处。所以这确实有助于整合这两者，比如，“是的，这些坏事发生了，但看看我是如何活下来的。看看我如何仍然在这里。看看我的神经系统为了让我保持安全和活着而采取的这些非常聪明的方式。”
system adapted to keep me safe and keep me alive. And you know, maybe now that I'm an adult, I don't need these things that I used to do, these strategies anymore. Maybe I can start to connect to others. Maybe I can, you know, start to feel again. Maybe I can start to feel more in my body because I am in a different place now than I was when I was six years old and I grew up in a really abusive household and not connecting and not feeling really helped keep me safe. And so that's the beauty of LI work is, you know, getting a sense of what are these adaptations that our nervous systems have made to keep
你知道，也许现在我是一个成年人了，我不再需要这些我过去常做的事情，这些策略了。也许我可以开始与他人建立联系。也许我可以，你知道，开始再次感受。也许我可以开始在我的身体里感受到更多，因为我现在所处的地方与我六岁时不同，我在一个非常虐待的家庭中长大，不建立联系和不感受确实有助于让我保持安全。所以这就是LI工作的魅力所在，你知道，去了解我们的神经系统为了保持
us safe, to protect us. And how can that change to fit our life now? Sorry guys, before we wrap up, I just want to throw out that this really has been really a life-changing modality for myself and for my clients. As I've been in allyotherapy for a while now, I have really experienced a lot of things shift and move for me and reactions that I don't have that I used to have. Things that used to would have really jarred me emotionally or really been heavy for me really aren't. I'm able to sort of acknowledge it and recognize other key people in my life. Whereas in the past, something they said or did might put me on edge and make me really uncomfortable. And today I can honestly say that like, I'm able to recognize those things as having occurred and that those people, you know, their perceptions of the
我们安全、保护我们而做出的这些适应是什么。以及这如何改变以适应我们现在的生活？抱歉，伙计们，在结束之前，我只想说，这对我自己和我的客户来说确实是一种改变生活的模式。自从我进行LI治疗一段时间以来，我确实经历了很多事情的转变和移动，以及我过去有但现在没有的反应。那些过去会让我情绪上非常不安或让我感到沉重的事情，现在真的不会了。我能够承认它并识别我生命中的其他关键人物。而在过去，他们说或做的事情可能会让我紧张并让我感到非常不舒服。而今天我可以诚实地说，我能够承认这些事情已经发生，并且那些人，你知道，他们对
experience is that it's theirs. It's not mine and I don't have to hold on to it. I don't have to carry that. And it's really just been a beautiful process of getting to learn myself and know myself and identify like who I am and you know what I what I get to do with my life moving forward that the things I have experienced do not have to define me moving forward. And also just wanted to add just one quick story. You know I had a client who had done some LI work and witnessed an accident. And so this person had been traveling to work on the way past this accident scene every day. And we talked about it one session after the accident happened.
这种经历的看法是他们自己的。不是我的，我不必坚持它。我不必背负它。这确实是一个了解自己、认识自己并识别我是谁，以及你知道我未来能用我的生活做什么的美好过程，我所经历的事情不必定义我的未来。另外还想补充一个简短的故事。你知道，我有一个做过一些LI工作的客户，目睹了一场事故。所以这个人每天都在去上班的路上经过这个事故现场。事故发生后，我们在一次会话中谈到了它。
And then the week after that, we actually did a PTSD timeline for that accident. And the client had been telling me literally that they were dreading passing that spot on the road for, you know, miles before they got there. And then following the PTOC timeline, they let me know in the next session that they had literally driven past the spot before they realized they passed the spot, I think, which is really telling to the power of this therapy. So that's what I have. Kristin, anything you want to add before we wrap up? Yeah, I mean, I've had many similar client experiences. It's really remarkable having clients come in and say, you know, I was having nightmares. I've had nightmares my entire life. And since we started this therapy, I'm no longer having nightmares. I'm no longer having flashbacks. I even have my own experience where I was in a car accident and had so much anxiety
然后在那之后的一周，我们实际上为那次事故做了一个PTSD时间线。客户确实告诉我，他们害怕经过路上的那个点，你知道，在他们到达那里之前的几英里。然后在PTOC时间线之后，他们在下一次会话中让我知道，他们实际上在意识到自己经过那个点之前就已经开车经过了那个点，我想，这确实说明了这种疗法的力量。这就是我所要说的。Kristin，在结束之前你有什么想补充的吗？是的，我的意思是，我有许多类似的客户经历。客户进来并说，“你知道，我一直在做噩梦。我一生都在做噩梦。自从我们开始这种疗法，我就不再做噩梦了。我不再有闪回。”这真的很了不起。我甚至有我自己的经历，我发生了一场车祸，对开车有太多的焦虑，
around driving and was constantly checking my rear view mirror like is someone about to crash into me. And after doing L.I. protocols, like notice like, okay, I'm not feeling that whenever I'm driving anymore. And so having experienced the power of L.I. myself and as Pamela said, just like noticing my transformation over time has really proven to me just how effective this modality is. And it's what has driven me to go through all the trainings, move towards certification. And I really love that L.I LI to move towards certification requires their therapists to
并且不断地检查我的后视镜，比如是否有人要撞到我。而在做完LI协议后，注意到，比如，“好的，我开车时不再有那种感觉了。”所以亲自体验了LI的力量，正如Pamela所说，就像注意到我随着时间的推移而发生的转变，这确实向我证明了这种模式是多么有效。这就是促使我完成所有培训，走向认证的原因。而且我真的很喜欢LI要求他们的治疗师
actually go through it themselves. So we are doing the work alongside our clients. We are not perfect human beings. We have our own trauma. It's really what led us to this work. And the healing that we've done around it is what allows us to hold space and really understand what it is that our clients are going through. And so in doing the LI work ourselves, you know, we're also able to be like, yeah, you
实际上自己也要经历它。所以我们正在与我们的客户一起做这项工作。我们不是完美的人类。我们有自己的创伤。这确实是引导我们从事这项工作的原因。我们在它周围所做的治愈使我们能够保持空间并真正理解我们的客户正在经历什么。所以通过我们自己做LI工作，你知道，我们也能够说，“是的，你知道，
know, like, this is tough work, but it's also really beautiful. And it's challenging in a very gentle way. And I'm here and I'm going to hold space for you. And we're going to get through this together. And so yeah, LA, I mean, I believe in the power of it. It's been transformational for me. And I've witnessed, LA, I mean, I believe in the power of it. It's been transformational for me and I've witnessed the transformation in many of my clients and it's just, it's amazing. I will share a personal anecdote real quick before we go. Because I haven't done quite as much work with my clients, but I've had a lot of it with my, you know, with my own therapist. but I've had a lot of it with my, you know, with my own therapist. And there was one protocol in particular that we did because I had a big presentation coming up. It was a webinar
这虽然是艰苦的工作，但它也非常美丽。它以一种非常温和的方式具有挑战性。我在这里，我会为你保持空间。我们将一起度过难关。”所以是的，LA，我的意思是，我相信它的力量。它对我来说是变革性的。而且我目睹了，LA，我的意思是，我相信它的力量。它对我来说是变革性的，我目睹了许多客户的转变，这真是太神奇了。在离开之前，我会快速分享一个个人轶事。因为我没有和我的客户做那么多工作，但我从我的，你知道，我自己的治疗师那里得到了很多。但在那之后，我从我的，你知道，我自己的治疗师那里得到了很多。有一个特定的协议我们做了，因为我有一个重要的演讲。这是一个网络研讨会，
and it ended up being 1200 people that were there. And I have struggled with public speaking my entire life. It's been a really stuck point in my life ever since I can remember. And we did a protocol before the presentation about a coping mechanism that I've had my entire life, which was staying quiet. Staying quiet has kept me safe. And I kind of observed that as my therapist was reading my timeline. And something shifted, the really cool part about LIs,
最终有1200人在那里。我一生都在与公开演讲作斗争。自从我记事起，它一直是我生活中一个非常卡住的点。在演讲之前，我们做了一个关于我一生中一直有的应对机制的协议，那就是保持安静。保持安静让我保持安全。当我的治疗师阅读我的时间线时，我观察到了这一点。有些东西发生了转变，LI非常酷的部分是，
we can't always detect, we almost can never detect actually when the shift occurs because it is so subtle. But the presentation was the following week, and 1200 people showed up. And I spoke for 30 minutes. And I was fine. And I had never done that in my life ever before. And I got done and I was like, I'm very suspicious. That's when I was still kind of new to ally myself. And I was like, there's no way. And I know that not every story is that magical, but for me, that was, it felt unreal
我们并不总是能检测到，实际上我们几乎永远无法检测到转变何时发生，因为它太微妙了。但演讲是在接下来的一周，1200人出现了。我讲了30分钟。我很好。我一生中从未做过那样的事情。我做完后，我就像，我非常怀疑。那时我还是LI的新手。我就像，这不可能。我知道并非每个故事都那么神奇，但对我来说，那感觉不真实，
that a shift that huge could take place and me not even recognize it, right? Like I call it behind the scenes therapy because we can't see it no idea what's happening because it's such a quiet process and it is you know it can be a little bit slower and a little bit more subtle but that was not subtle for me at all that was the opposite of subtle I just had no idea what was happening so that was a big thing for sure Pamela looks great um yeah and we are out of time but just a couple of things I wanted to throw in you That was a big one. Great. Thanks for sharing that, Pamela.
如此巨大的转变竟然发生了，而我甚至没有意识到，对吧？就像我称之为幕后疗法，因为我们看不到它，不知道发生了什么，因为它是一个如此安静的过程，而且它，你知道，它可以稍微慢一点，稍微微妙一点，但那对我来说一点也不微妙，那与微妙完全相反。我只是不知道发生了什么，所以那确实是一件大事。Pamela看起来很棒，嗯，是的，我们的时间到了，但只是有几件事我想补充，你，那是一个大问题。太棒了。谢谢你的分享，Pamela。
That's great. Yeah, and we are out of time, but just a couple of things I wanted to throw in. You know, if you're thinking about considering a lie, like, you know, kind of informed consent about therapy is like it is a hard process. It can be very challenging. It has brought up a lot of things that I maybe didn't consciously remember or connect with. And it has it has challenged me to face things that are very uncomfortable as does any therapy especially trauma therapy
太棒了。是的，我们的时间到了，但只是有几件事我想补充。你知道，如果你正在考虑LI，就像，你知道，关于疗法的知情同意就像它是一个艰难的过程。它可能非常有挑战性。它带出了很多我可能没有有意识地记住或联系起来的事情。它挑战我面对非常不舒服的事情，就像任何疗法，特别是创伤疗法一样。
But I can absolutely say it as it sounds like Kristen and Pamela would also is that it is worth it It is worth the challenge. It is worth some of the pain to get through the other side To really experience some of that freedom and yeah Kristen mentioned nightmares just a couple of things that I noticed people really aspire to get some relief from pretty quickly is nightmares. Increased auto response, feeling tense, keyed up and on edge.
但我绝对可以说，听起来Kristen和Pamela也会这么说，它是值得的。它值得挑战。它值得经历一些痛苦来到达另一边，真正体验那种自由。是的，Kristen提到了噩梦，我注意到人们确实渴望很快得到一些缓解的几件事是噩梦。增加自动反应，感到紧张，焦虑和处于边缘。
Just so those sort of states that are, our systems are sort of, for a lot of us have sort of existed in survival for a very long time. If not, since we were created in the womb, some of us have really been in that survival state from day one. And so it really does help to start to settle
只是那些状态，我们的系统，对我们很多人来说，已经在生存状态中存在了很长一段时间。如果不是从我们在子宫里被创造出来开始，我们有些人确实从第一天起就一直处于那种生存状态。所以它确实有助于开始平息
a lot of those little things that are just brought up because our system is just trying to keep us safe. Because we're able to recognize that present safety, like Kristen said in the beginning, we always end in the present moment. So something that happened yesterday or today, something recent, and then you're right here with me in present time. And that has been a really great tool for a lot of my clients.
很多那些只是因为我们的系统试图让我们保持安全而产生的小事情。因为我们能够识别那种当下的安全，就像Kristen在开始时说的，我们总是以当下时刻结束。所以昨天或今天发生的事情，最近发生的事情，然后你就在当下和我在一起。这对我的许多客户来说是一个非常好的工具。
I've even had clients who told me outside of session, they can actually kind of hear my voice going, and you're right here with me in the present time. And like, they just recognize that safety. So I really think that, of course, informed consent, like it's hard, but it's worth it. It's 100% worth it. Anything else you want to add before we wrap up? All right. Well, so glad we could do this today, guys. And we appreciate everybody who's listening. And you can check out our other blogs on Tupperware Therapy Collective, and we'll see you again next week. Bye guys.
我甚至有客户告诉我，在会话之外，他们实际上可以听到我的声音说，“你就在当下和我在一起。”而且，他们只是识别那种安全感。所以我真的认为，当然，知情同意，它很难，但它是值得的。它是100%值得的。在结束之前你还有什么想补充的吗？好的。好吧，很高兴我们今天能做到这一点，伙计们。我们感谢每一位正在收听的人。你可以查看我们在Tupperware Therapy Collective上的其他博客，我们下周再见。再见，伙计们。
Hey guys, I wanted to pop in here to give you a quick reminder that we do this podcast for free and there are significant expenses associated with it, including the biggest resource of my life right now, which is time. One of the things that would really help us and hopefully would help you would be to check out one of our sponsors, Hardy Nutritionals. Hardy is a vitamin company that I never encountered the advertising of. We heard over and over again from multiple people with treatment resistant anxiety and dopamine disorders like bipolar disorder and other things that they had tried everything and Hardy was what worked. And so I checked them out and they have really good research. I'm not a fan
嘿，伙计们，我想插进来提醒你们一下，我们免费做这个播客，并且与之相关的费用很高，包括我生命中目前最大的资源，那就是时间。真正能帮助我们，也希望对你们有帮助的一件事是查看我们的赞助商之一，Hardy Nutritionals。Hardy是一家我从未遇到过广告的维生素公司。我们一次又一次地从多个患有难治性焦虑症和多巴胺障碍（如双相情感障碍和其他疾病）的人那里听说，他们尝试了一切，而Hardy是有效的。所以我查看了他们，他们有非常好的研究。我不喜欢
of a lot of the BS that's in the supplement and wellness space. Hardy paid for a lot of research on their product and when I ordered some for myself I saw a big difference in my life and my wife made fun of me, thought it was going to be Alex Jones selling vitamins on the radio and when she tried them she really liked them too. There's a lot of data about how they can reduce the symptoms of ADHD without medications or lower your need for medication, also manage some of the effects of autism spectrum disorder and a whole lot of other things. Newer research around nutrition is saying that the synergistic effects of multiple things
补充剂和健康领域中很多胡说八道的东西。Hardy为他们的产品支付了很多研究费用，当我为自己订购了一些时，我看到了我生活中的巨大差异，我妻子取笑我，以为这会是Alex Jones在广播里卖维生素，当她尝试它们时，她也非常喜欢它们。有很多关于它们如何在没有药物的情况下减少ADHD症状或降低你对药物的需求，以及管理自闭症谱系障碍的一些影响和许多其他事情的数据。关于营养的较新研究表明，多种事物的协同效应
being planned to work together is a lot more effective than one thing working alone. You can get a lot of information about that on our website or you can head over to gethardy.com and use offer code taproot for 15% off. It would help them, it would help me, and it also would probably help you. One of the more frequent things that patients and people in the randomized controlled trials that Hardy conducted report is that they feel more themselves, more focused and more effective at getting things done, which can result in all of us having a little bit more time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
被计划在一起工作比单一事物单独工作要有效得多。你可以在我们的网站上获得很多关于这方面的信息，或者你可以前往gethardy.com并使用优惠码taproot获得15%的折扣。这会帮助他们，会帮助我，也可能会帮助你。Hardy进行的随机对照试验中的患者和人们报告的最常见的事情之一是，他们感觉更像自己，更专注，更有效地完成事情，这可以导致我们所有人多一点时间。此剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子以发表评论。